it truly is a sad day in hollywood as we
remember a star who brought us so much
joy the remarkable betty white her
career spanned 80 years she had a hit tv
show at the age of 93. you know betty
has been a part of our lives for so long
it really is hard that we now have to
say goodbye
you don't think of
accomplishing
things but
you also
subconsciously
you work for the things you really
believe in
that was september 2017 our final et sit
down with betty who was 95 years young
at the time what is the secret to your
longevity
blessed with good health
really good health i love a cocktail i
love i love
peanut butter and jelly and stuff but i
don't abuse
the things that that i know if if you're
blessed with this good health you should
take advantage of it
this is one of the icons last public
appearances she was all smiles running
errands the day before her 98th birthday
betty continued working doing mostly
voice over work she maintained her sassy
and irreverent sense of humor i mean
remember this dab
it remains one of the best gifts ever
are you ever going to retire no of
course not i don't think so what
you are the most remarkable woman in the
business
who
no
i'm the luckiest old brother in the
business when you figure i'm still
working at this age
you are a woman who loves to work what
is it that makes you want to come to
work every single day oh i just love i'm
so lucky to be in this business i never
take it for granted at my age i should
have been thrown out a long time ago but
i uh i love to work you work with the
nicest people in the world
and they take such good care of you i
want to offer you a traditional
scandinavian wedding blessing
deflector fluffing flapping person
the golden girl's life secret she said
see the funny side not the downside i
get bored with people that complain it's
such a waste of time and as for how
she's viewed death it was actually quite
beautiful
it's lovely to think
there is something we don't know
and
as as a human race we have learned so
much and we've gained so much knowledge
but that's something
nobody knows what happens
afterwards
it's a secret
let's go back to betty's comedy career
because as we've seen she's been part of
some game-changing sitcoms but she
credits the mary tyler moore show for
helping her get her groove back
nobody misses a vain selfish egotistical
middle-aged true of course we do
sure turned my career around because if
that character hadn't been written
usually the the star's friend was
somebody on her side
where suanne came in you know and just
caused a little habit being fired is
like being violated
leave it to murray to find a bright spot
suanne nivens the happy man hungry
homemaker didn't appear until the fourth
season of the show betty was only hired
for a one-time guest spot at the
suggestion of her close personal friend
mary tyler moore
that must be lars mark
mylar he offered to take me home wasn't
that nice of him but betty's sharp
comedic timing and skillful delivery of
saucy one-liners impressed producers
enough to bring her back oh mary really
if i had a date would i be coming to
your party
and while she only appeared in 45 of the
168 episodes of the classic 70s sitcom
betty turned suan into one of tv's most
memorable characters
suan became sort of an entity you know
it was oh it was the luckiest thing that
ever happened to me reuniting for a cbs
special in 1991 it was easy to see betty
and her co-stars were bonded for life it
is heaven i tell you we all walked into
the makeup trailer together
and
the the sides bulged we haven't stopped
talking since it's just i cannot tell
you the thrill it is to be back together
but the true legacy of the show and
betty was the groundbreaking portrayal
of working women something betty was
immensely proud of it was the first time
that it was all right for a lady over 30
single uh to be in business and
independent for herself that seems like
a formula now but that it hadn't been
done before
betty was breaking barriers throughout
her career winning over a new generation
of fans well into her 80s we love you we
love you i love you
i'm here tonight because you wanted me
to be
in 2010 at the age of 88 betty became
the oldest person ever to host snl she
got the gig after fans campaigned for
her on facebook i didn't know what
facebook was
and now that i do know what it is i have
to say
it sounds like a huge waste of time
when the whole thing came about i said
thank you so much but no i can't and my
agent said yes you will you have to do
that it was the scariest thing i've ever
done
but it was a lovely challenge i'm betty
freaking white and this is jay-z
i'm the bodyguard i can brag to all my
friends who think i'm you know over the
hill
well i did a sketch with jay-z feisty
fearless and forever young at heart
betty was always ready to take on a new
challenge like this tv land ugly betty
spoof they came and took a mold in my
mouth and now i've got braces i hope
they come off if you must know it feels
terrible i've been in this
silly this lovely business for 62 years
and they haven't caught on to me yet
they will any minute and i've been
abusing the privilege lately but as long
as they keep asking i
keep saying okay she even signed on to
do a sitcom hot in cleveland with
valerie bertinelli in 2010. when the
show wrapped in 2015 betty was 93. so
what are you like a hundred
i don't like you
i've been around so long kevin
but it's all of a sudden things kind of
exploded and i'm just riding the wave
and having a wonderful time i screwed up
a line right but that wasn't one line
betty loved a good martini just as much
as she loved acting and not just on tv
betty made her mark in movies too
alongside a-listers like kristen bell in
you again so grandma is there anything i
can help you with
oh dear and ryan reynolds and sandra
bullock in the proposal proving you're
never too old to be sassy let's see if
we can find your boobs
they're in there somewhere you know what
i love we go out to dinner she pulls up
in her caddy she pulls up they've got
her table ms white right here you know
everyone sort of bows to miss white they
sit her down they give her her drink
they know what she likes and she just
commands the room it's our last day of
shooting on the proposal she's walking
out the door and the crew is just giving
her this insane standing ovation and she
sort of raises her hand and she's the
best exit i've ever seen for any
entertainer she was like this is the
most fun i've ever had and they all went
oh and she went standing up and then
walked out of the room and it just was
the best it was like she invented the
mic drop betty's second act redefined
aging in hollywood and secured her
status as a beloved icon so it's no
surprise when her 98th birthday came
around everyone wanted to send her their
heartfelt well wishes happy birthday
dear baby
happy birthday betty white i love you
you're such an inspiration for all of us
i got to present at the emmys with betty
white did you really
and i had to do a quick change
in like a little
curtained off area she was standing
right next to me how about our sexual
chemistry back in that quick change room
betty i hope you enjoyed that and happy
birthday
what advice would you have for people
that want to have not just a career in
hollywood but a long and happy career in
hollywood
don't take yourself too seriously you
know keep keep your eye on the other guy
and try to fit in with there don't think
it's all about you because it isn't